the opening scene features a successful
contractor Clint Goodman who lives with
his pretty wife Joanna while at work he
calls his wife and tells her that he's
going to miss her since she's going off
to work during the weekends however
Joanna doesn't seem to be pleased with
him at all later on Clint attends one of
his clients who is there to offer him a
good deal for his business after work he
drives his way back home when he is
pulled over by a local sheriff Sam
Abberly turns out that the sheriff is
Clint's friend who invites him to go
fishing together going to have to give
you a ticket for being so dang good at
baiting worms on a hook buddy Clint
gives an honest Ascent responding that
since Joanna is gone for the weekend he
has a free spot available upon arriving
back home he sets his dog Duke free from
its cage before joining his wife in the
kitchen he tells her about the client
who came to offer a million and a half
for his business but he turned him down
this news agitates Joanna who then
expresses how she wants to live in the
city instead of being caged up in this
rural Farmhouse like a rat in a maze the
discussion eventually escalates to an
argument and Clint reminds her that he
traveled 2,000 miles from the bustling
New York and built this house so that
they can live a better life together
however Joanna doesn't seem to
understand this so she storms off in her
sports car that evening Clint goes out
with the sheriff and while they fish Sam
asks how things are going with Joanna
Clint then confides everything in him
including how she being a city girl
craves City Life instead of some quiet
Country House meanwhile it is revealed
that Joanna is having an affair with a
local doctor Court Van Owen if you've
got a van in your name you're definitely
banging someone's wife the doctor tells
her how together they can own a clinic
in Beverly Hills as well as other
Pleasures Joanna offers to get a divorce
from her husband but courland suggests
that she rather get rid of him
permanently he then pulls out a vial
containing toxins which he extracted
from the ovaries of one of his exotic
fish he asks her to mix it in her
husband's food or drink after which the
recipient will die of a heart attack
Joanna is initially hesitant but
courland slips the tiny vial into her
bag asking her to reconsider as soon as
she reaches home she empties her purse
looking for the poison she accidentally
drops it causing it to start leaking
reluctant to do such a heinous crime she
tosses the Bottle Into the trash bin
later Clint returns home and greets his
wife who is preparing dinner he kisses
her and tells her that he'll be working
at his home workshop for a while soon
after the disturbing noise from the
workshop irritates Joanna causing her to
rethink her decision she then retrieves
the leftover poison from the trash bin
and pours it into his drink at the same
time Clint startles her from behind and
grabs both wine glasses helping her set
the table while having their dinner
Joanna is scared to take a sip of her
wine unsure of which cup contains the
poison inconceivable as a result she
waits for Clint to finish his wine
however her anxiety heightens when he
asks her to toast with him in the midst
of her indecision the poison seems to
kick in as Clint begins to convulse in
excruciating pain he pleads for Joanna's
help but she callously urges him to die
instead he eventually stops struggling
and collapses seemingly succumbing to a
heart attack Joanna then calls courland
to infirm him that the deed is done in
the aftermath Sheriff Sam and his
officers accompanied by courland arrived
to retrieve Clint's lifeless body
saddened Sam feels suspicious about the
sudden heart attack as he looked
completely fine when they went fishing
earlier that day He suggests that they
should get an autopsy but courland
somehow manages to convince him that it
won't be necessary following this
Clint's Body is taken to a morg where he
Witnesses a small movement indicating
that he might be alive the following
morning Clint's Body is taken out by the
morticians to prepare for the funeral
just then Courtland calls the funeral
home and tells them that Joanna wants
Clint to be given a quick funeral
skipping the embalming process and
choosing a cheap water- damaged casket
for him the scene then cuts to the
funeral during which Duke keeps on
barking as Joanna approaches the casket
to put her flowers on she also puts on a
show of mourning figting tears and
distress later that night Joanna is seen
enjoying a drink with courland in her
bathtub meanwhile Duke is still barking
midst the heavy rain this annoys the
jerk so she grabs Clint's shotgun and
heads outside to gun down the dog
however as soon as she opens the cage
Duke manages to run away she's got some
balls for what she's done Duke should
have bitten them off he makes his way to
the cemetery and sits down next to
Clint's grave the rain loosens the soil
causing it to start seeping into the
coffin this unexpected intrusion awakens
Clint finally confirming that he is in
fact still alive as the water drips on
his face Clint panics and puts all of
his efforts to get out of the coffin
thankfully due to the shabby nature of
it he manages to make his way out of it
Duke is initially scared but he stays at
a distance and Barks until his owner
emerges from his grave following this
Clint returns home but finds the front
door locked he goes to the kitchen
window only to witness his wife kissing
Courtland that doctor has a PHD in being
an [__] being in a weakened State
Clint opts to wait for courland to
depart after which he breaks into the
basement of the house and spends the
rest of the night there there the next
day Joanna meets with Clint's lawyer who
hands over important property documents
as well as Clint's Bank details to her
as they Converse she also tells the
lawyer that she's willing to sell her
husband's business for 1 A2 million with
the condition that the payment must be
done in cash within 48 Hours meanwhile
at the basement Clint wakes up and heads
upstairs still appearing weak he first
goes to the kitchen sink to gulp down
some water and then moves to the fridge
to take a bite out of the food not long
after he notices Joanna arriving in her
car so he returns to the basement he
then grabs his shotgun and loads it with
an intent to shoot his cheating wife
however before he can do so the doorbell
rings Johanna opens the door to sheriff
Sam who has come over to check up on her
he expresses his concern about the for
sale sign outside the house and asks if
she's leaving town in response Joanna
pretends that there are too many
memories in this house which is making
it hard for her to stay after a while
courland shows up and covers his
presence he claims that Joanna is his
patient and he's here to check up on her
upon Sam's departure Joanna tells her
boyfriend that they have to leave
immediately because she fears that the
sheriff might be on to them however
Courtland calms her down and convinces
her to stay for one more night since the
money from selling the business will
come the next day amidst their
conversation courland reminds her how
she was pregnant and how he helped her
with the abortion process so that she
would not have to stay with Clint Clint
who has been overhearing their
conversation is clearly disheartened by
this Revelation now that his heart is
filled with rage and Vengeance he takes
out the bullets thinking that using the
G would be an easy punishment for them
later that night as Joanna falls asleep
Clint grabs a pair of scissors from the
room and heads up into the bathroom he
cleans himself up tends to his hand
wounds and wraps them up with bandages
before walking away the following
morning Sheriff Sam along with his
officers arrives at the cemetery to find
Clint's grave dug up and the body
missing the sheriff orders the casket be
sent to his home and asks that the
investigation be kept confidential until
he completes it in the meantime Clint's
client arrives at the house and hands to
Joanna a briefcase full of cash sealing
off the deal after the men leave Joanna
is super excited to leave the place with
courland she then enters the bathroom to
wash up only to discover that the place
is covered with mud all over she
frantically rushes to call courland but
he doesn't answer as a result she leaves
a voicemail warning him that someone
might be inside the house in a
precautionary move she goes to retrieve
the gun from the basement but she's
startled by Duke she grabs the gun and
prepares to shoot him but Clint suddenly
appears from behind wearing a welding
mask but he's not here to weld their
relationship back together this prompts
her to pull the trigger and its recoil
throws her into the basement knocking
her unconscious Clint then locks her
inside and goes around to seal the
windows and all possible exits on the
other hand courland loads a syringe with
more fish poison and makes his way to
Joanna's Place upon arrival he takes out
the syringe and begins calling out for
Joanna but she doesn't answer he then
walks upstairs to her bedroom and finds
the Briefcase full of money shortly
after Joanna wakes up and hears courland
calling her name repeatedly thinking
that he was the one who scared her
earlier she hides under the stairs and
waits for him to enter the basement as
soon as he does she hits him with a
metal rod dropping the poison injection
out of his hand she then takes the money
and tries to escape but Clint shows up
and locks them both inside convinced
that there is a third person in the
house she regrets her action and
apologizes to courland when she tells
him about the third person courland
tells her that they have to get out
first he loads the shotgun and tries to
unlock the door by shooting at it but
soon realizes that the bullets are empty
following this he tries to break open a
wooden window but Duke starts barking at
them forcing him to retreat upstairs
Clint is working on remodeling the house
and even saws through his wedding
picture 8 hours pass by and courland
assumes that it's Sheriff Sam who's
doing all of this to them so that he can
have a share of their wealth amidst this
Joanna spots the syringe filled with
poison lying on the floor she picks it
up and realizes that kland was intending
to kill her when she confronts him
regarding this courland reveals that
there never was a clinic and that he was
actually trying to rob her in order to
pay off his personal debt enraged by
this Revelation Joanna attacks him with
the syringe but fails to inject him he
eventually gets his hand on the
injection and attempts to administer the
poison to her right then the basement
door opens and Joanna convinces him not
to waste the dose on her upon exiting
the basement the duo finds that most of
the house is now blocked off by wooden
panels while trying to find a way out
they are LED through a maze soon after a
wall emerges between the two causing
them to be separated after this another
door opens from courtland's side
revealing a passage to an unlocked
window at the end of the passage he sees
a shadowy figure and thinking that it's
Sam he tries to bribe him as he
approaches the figure Clint suddenly
reveals himself a stunned Courtland
tries to flee but trips on the briefcase
of money and falls on the syringe sweet
baby irony Clint then goes after Joanna
chasing her through a small hatch she
crawls through the hatchway along a low
path passage and ends up inside a wooden
coffin allowing Clint to shut her inside
at this point Clint finally reveals
himself to her and asserts that this is
how it feels to be a rat in a maze he
also mentions their aborted child asking
if it was a boy or a girl but receives
no answer he then dumps the dead
Courtland and money inside the same
coffin and Nails it shut next he pours
gasoline all over the place and sets the
entire house on fire with this Clint and
Duke Drive Away from the scene with the
wooden coffin behind behind their truck
meanwhile Sam is investigating the
shabby coffin and soon figures out that
Clint had escaped by himself with this
realization he rushes to Clint's place
and finds the house on fire he
immediately calls the fire department to
have the Flames extinguished once done
he inspects the entire place but finds
no bodies inside following this the
sheriff returns to the cemetery and sees
a man standing at Clint's filled-in
grave with a shovel when he realizes
that it's Clint Sam tells him to go away
and never come back indirectly promising
to keep this incident a secret as Clint
and Duke Drive Away we see this still
alive Joanna the dead Courtland and the
money are now buried in Clint's grave
the movie ends with Joanna hopelessly
screaming for help subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching